[Musique]
je suis sûre exter
je veux savoir
si je veux pas savoir alors nous y voilà
tous aiment
bien sûr je sais quelques petites choses
à force de lire des livres mais je suis
censé croire que cet anglais n'existe
pas pourquoi ça ne suffit pas pour que
ton mari ne suffit-il pas vous couchez
encore ensemble j'aurais parié tu me
poserait cette question j'aime savoir ce
qui se passe dans ta tête mais j'ai pas
l'intention d'y répondre
à supposer que je meure écrin biographe
tombe sur ton nom qu'est ce que tu veux
dire est il n'a pas écrit un seul de ses
livres ils ont été écrits par toute une
série de maîtresses et moi j'ai écrit
les deux derniers émois 6 à l'humilier
c'est un jeu
il est où mon livre quel est le livre
dans lequel je suis et je suis venu un
temps dentelle et tu as voulu que je
monte dans ta chambre
et la petite américaine il faut lui ses
quais en fait je sais bien que très
vaguement du tout ah bah désolé
naturel mort tu m'as manqué qu'est ce
qui te manquer je veux savoir non pas de
progrès voici te plait je suis un
écouteur je suis un audiophile le duo
filmé mais quelle connerie prétentieuse
très antique
[Musique]
ll n'est que des mots mais j'ai beau
essayer je suis pas capable de baisers
des mots je me fous de ce que les gens
comprennent ne comprennent pas ou qu'on
prenne trop bien
[Musique]
ati donc qu'est ce qui va se passer
quand tu veux te demander d'où vient ce
bleu sur la cuisse il a déjà fait au
alors j'ai dit la vérité toujours la
vérité comme ça on se laisse piéger par
le mensonge
[Musique]